hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen serie bzw einem contest wo
ihr nämlich auch mal mit eingebunden
werden in die sachen die ich in dieser
serie machen werde
ich sag ja sonst mal mega pro jahr
schreibt kommentare und das darauf gehe
ich dann ein und zwar das alles mache
ich ja natürlich auch aber dass ich noch
mehr auf euch eingehe und zwar ist es
ein skin contest der vermutlich
wöchentlich vielleicht aber nur alle
zwei wochen nicht ganz einfach die
besten skins der woche seine serie wo
ich halt die skins vorstelle die mir
zugesendet werden jetzt fragt euch
natürlich hey das ist die erste folge wo
kriegt jetzt die ersten skins her
ich habe jetzt einfach irgendwelche bei
planet minecraft aus dem skins links
durch bin alle seiten irgendwie
durchgegangen aus papier oder sachen hab
mir da 50 skins rausgesucht die ich sehr
geil finde es packt ihr euch in die
beschreibung dass ihr euch downloaden
könnt und also ich packte ihr euch von
der seite novas can eine beschreibung
wie ihr die downloaden könnt das werdet
ihr wohl selbst herausfinden oder halt
irgendwelche anderen werden euch das
schon erklären in den kommentaren wenn
ihr dann einfach fragt er steht irgendwo
download oder so und dann könnt ihr euch
die selbst herunterladen so und zwar
werdet ihr in dieser serie demnach
eingebunden dass ihr mir jetzt in die
kommentare schreiben könnt euren
minecraft ingame namen oder halt
irgendein kleines kind vorstellen kann
oder mir per facebook-nachricht
irgendeinen skin senden könnte oder
irgendwie sowas am besten wäre es echt
wenn ihr einfach irgendein skin anzieht
den egal findet oder wenn ihr einen skin
geil findet habt ihr ihn wahrscheinlich
auch ärztin und dann schreibt ihm
einfach euren minecraft ingame namen und
dann kann es sein dass eventuell in der
nächsten folge skin der woche dabei sein
bzw
skins zumindest und ihr werdet dann
namentlich erwähnt also eigentlich ein
sehr simples prinzip ihr seht gerade im
hintergrund übrigens mit survival games
runde die ich ein bisschen vorgespult
habe am ende mache ich dann die musik
einfach noch ein bisschen lauter weil
die ware schon recht relativ lang am
anfang habe ich keine kisten gefunden
und dann habe ich aber ein team gemacht
mit zwei anderen leuten was ihr geld
dann habe ich am ende sogar noch
gewonnen und java sehr witzig also ich
würde sagen wir fangen jetzt einfach mal
an und zwar blende ich euch die skins
immer so oben links ein ich habe damals
ein paar screenshots vorn gemacht und
zwar
ist für mich also ich sag jetzt nicht
platz fünf weil es sind alles fünf erste
plätze und nicht erste zeit dritter
vierter fünfter platz
kommen wir zum ersten skin und zwar ist
das der von captain sparkle in dem video
wollen kingdom dieser typ da der dieser
dieser prinz oder dieser könig der halt
da die ganze welt regiert und dann
nachher bricht deshalb so alles zusammen
also das ist es geht auf jeden fall da
wo noch alles okay war
finde ich sehr geil auch dass das des
mit mehreren ebenen gemacht wurde
also man sieht ja zum beispiel bei den
ansichten die haare oder die krone oder
so das waren auf jeden fall verschiedene
ebenen
das ist auf jeden fall sehr geil also
das ist schon mal ein der schon mal
dabei dann ist donald duck dabei auch
mit mehreren ebenen arten gearbeitet und
zwar ist da so dieser schnabel in einer
anderen ebene dann dieser seemann zu gut
da hinten dieser faden und so was alles
also finde ich auch sehr witzig donald
duck skin wollte ich eigentlich auch
erster nehmen bevor ich mir dann diesen
r villages kind geholt hat übrigens
apropos zum villagers genommene
anmerkung wollt ihr dass ich einen skin
pack mache mit meinen villagers kinn mit
verschiedenen masken also mit meinem
anzug aber dann zum beispiel dann mal
mit der kripo maske oder mit einem
anderen kopf oder mit einer schweins
maske oder irgendwie sowas soll soll ich
so was von machen dann geht mal bitte
einfach den daumen hoch und schreib mir
das in den kommentaren ob ich das machen
soll eventuell schaffen irgendwie 2000
daumen hoch dass wir auf jeden fall
schon echt hammer und dann kann ich an
mich war sommer und so was dran setzen
und das dann auch hochladen also
schreibt mir das einfach in die
kommentare
also zwei das kind war donald duck
drittens habe ich pinocchio rausgesucht
und zwar habe ich einfach mal nach
pinocchio gegoogelt nach pinocchio
microsofts kin weil meine schwester hat
pinocchio geguckt und dann dachte ich
mir so witzig kann ich eigentlich
nachkommen vielleicht gibt es ja näher
ans kinn mit der nase die nase ist
natürlich auf einer anderen ebene weil
die nase wächst natürlich wenn er lügt
und der komplette rücken ist glaube ich
auch auf einer anderen ebene da bin ich
mir nicht so sicher
jetzt bin ich ein bisschen verrutscht
und zwar auch so die die der hut sowie
welt an und ab und zu was alles also bin
ich auf jeden fall sehr geil dem kino
kiosken auch dass da somit das halt die
ärmel nicht nur in gelb sind sondern
wirklich den zombie stammer wieder dann
wiederum brauchen also übergänge halt
das sieht auf jeden fall sehr
glaubwürdig und sehr geil auch aus das
kind finde ich dann noch einen skin ist
godzilla finde ich auch sehr geil wollte
ich sogar eigentlich verwenden jetzt als
neues allerdings schreibt mir meine
kommentare ob ihr damit zufrieden wert
oder ob ich lieber den posten behalten
soll weil ich glaube ich behalten doch
die bei den villagers kind aber
verändert die noch mal ein bisschen
vielleicht einen anderen anzug anziehen
vielleicht mal die konturen die
sättigung ein bisschen hoch stellen dass
ich da nicht so ein trüber traufen elend
bin darüber tropfen elend trüber haufen
elend saß also godzilla auch wieder mit
mehreren ebenen gearbeitet wie zum
beispiel diese stacheln am rücken und so
was alles finde ich auch sehr geil und
machen das heißt platz eins also der
skin der auch noch dabei ist der von
blue monkey animations- von youtube blue
monkey you tube heißt der blue monkey
world heißt er in minecraft und zwar
dass so ein affe mit krawatte und das
finde ich richtig geil
also ich mag den skin über alles also
ich würde ich nicht empfehlen ihn zu
nehmen falls ein skin ist aber ich finde
den mega geil wenn er den ich hätte dann
würde ich den online weil der ist
megageil ich liebe dieses kind einfach
diesen affen
ich weiß nicht ich feiere das völlig
feiern naja freunde das waren auf jeden
fall die schon die ersten 15 20 alles
günstig rausgesucht habe natürlich baut
die serie darauf auf dass ihr mir skins
in die kommentare schreibt deswegen
schreibt jetzt in die kommentare eure
minecraft in dem namen und zieht
natürlich dann auch euren skin dann an
den ich vorstellen soll eventuell schaue
ich mir das dann mal an und stellt euch
dann demnächst wieder ein paar skins vor
und dann werden das dann halt eures kind
sein und nicht die die ich ausgesucht
hat so download links und in der
beschreibung wie immer wenn es euch
gefallen hat und je mehr als kind
contest wollt dann könnt ihr einfach den
daumen hoch geben
das zeigt mir dass es euch gefallen hat
und dass eventuell mehr wollten das euch
einmal die neue serie gefällt dieser
contest dass sie ein bisschen
eingebunden werden auch wenn ihr noch
andere ideen habe ich euch noch mehr
einbinden kann in bestimmten serien oder
so also serien vorschläge oder playlist
video vorschläge könnt ihr alles in die
kommentare schreiben genauso wie mit
eurem skin die ich an anziehen werde
wie gesagt es in der beschreibung
facebook twitter instagram und auch live
stream ist mittlerweile in der
beschreibung verlinkt die runde geht
jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter hierzu
bei will games bzw hunger games nicht
dass er immer da ist auf jeden fall noch
was gutes heraus entstanden und dann
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns dann
eventuell nächste woche wieder
eventuelle zwei wochen wie gesagt es
heißt weil die scans der woche welchen
namen brauchte und diese erika normale
man kann also nicht rumheulen sondern
lieber video schauen und kommentieren